GREG GUTFELD AND JESSE
WATTERS.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS "THE FIVE."
THE IMMIGRATION BATTLE FRONT
AND CENTER AS THE FIRST WAVE
OF THE CARAVAN IS MET WITH
VIOLENCE IN TEE YUANNA,
MEXICO.
LOCAL RESIDENTS CLASHING
WITH THE MIGRANTS AND
CHANTING THIS.
[CHANTING]
[MEXICO]
>> Dana: POTENTIAL 2020
HOPEFUL KAMALA HARRIS FACING
BACKLASH AFTER THIS EXCHANGE
DURING A CONFIRMATION
HEARING FOR THE NOMINEE TO
HEAD ICE.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF THE
PERCEPTION OF MANY ABOUT HOW
THE POWER AND THE DISCRETION
AT ICE IS BEING USED TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY
PARALLELS.
>> I DO NOT SEE ANY
PARALLELS BETWEEN.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT
PERCEPTION.
>> OFFICERS AND AGENTS.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT
PERCEPTION.
>> I DO NOT SEE A PARALLEL
BETWEEN WHAT IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED AS
IT RELATES TO ENFORCING THE
LAW.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE
IS A PERCEPTION --
>> -- I SEE NO.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE
IS A PERCEPTION.
>> TO PUT ICE IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE KKK.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE ASKING
ME?
>> NO, I'M VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT I'M ASKING YOU.
ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE IS
A PERCEPTION THAT ICE IS
ADMINISTERING ITS POWER IN A
WAY THAT IS CAUSING FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION, PARTICULARLY
AMONG IMMIGRANTS?
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT.
HE KEPT HIS COOL THERE,
GREG.
>> Greg: YEAH, I RESPECT
HER, BUT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
A VERY SLEAZY, SLEAZY MOVE.
IT'S A WAY OF ASKING A
QUESTION WITHOUT ASKING A
QUESTION.
SOME WOULD SAY, JESSE, THAT
YOU DRINK HEAVILY, NOT ME
BUT SOME WOULD SAY.
THAT'S WHAT SHE DID.
SHE SAID THERE IS A
PERCEPTION OF WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY TO THE PERCEPTION AND
THE THING IS THE ONLY REASON
WHY THE PERCEPTION WOULD
EXIST IS BECAUSE SHE IS
LAYING THE PERCEPTION OUT
THERE.
YOU KNOW, SOME MAY SAY THAT
ICE IS LIKE THE KKK.
YOU ARE THE SOME.
BUT YOU ARE TOO COWARDLY TO
ADMIT THAT YOU ARE THE SOME.
SO, I WOULD THOUGHT THAT
STUNK TO HIGH HEAVEN.
HE ANSWERED IT CORRECTLY.
>> Dana: AGAIN, HE IS TRYING
TO GET CONFIRMED TO BE THE
HEAD.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, I DON'T
THINK YOU DRINK HEAVILY.
>> Jesse: IF THERE IS A
PERCEPTION.
>> Greg: I SAW YOU IN MY EYE
LINE.
>> Jesse: SHOW IS GETTING
OFF TO A GREAT START.
>> Dana: HAPPY FRIDAY.
>> Greg: SOME WOULD SAY YOUR
HAIR IS BEAUTIFUL, JESSE.
>> Dana: SOME WOULD SAY IT'S
YOUR TURN TO TALK.
>> Jesse: FIRST OF ALL,
CAMLA, WHAT SHE DID, I
AGREE, YOU CAN'T FRAME THE
QUESTION AS GUILT BY
ASSOCIATION.
I CAN SAY THERE IS A
PERCEPTION DEMOCRATS ARE
PRO-CRIME AND OPEN BORDERS.
THEREOF IS MORE OF A
PERCEPTION THAN THAT THAN
THERE IS A PERCEPTION THAT
ICE IS AKIN TO THE KKK.
NOW, HER HISTORY BOOKS.
THE CAN KK TERRORIZED THE
SOUTH FOR DECADES AND HUNG
INNOCENT AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THEY WERE SUPPORTED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, OKAY?
SHE, AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
SENATOR, SHOULD KNOW THAT
AND THAT COMPARISON IS SO
OUTLANDISH AND SO
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE ICE
AGENTS THAT ARE JUST DOING
THEIR JOB.
DO YOU KNOW WHO IS REALLY
SCARED OF ICE AND WHO SHOULD
BE SCARED?
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, DRUG
TRAFFICKERS, CRIMINAL
ILLEGALS THAT HAVE SKIPPED
BAIL AND ARE NOW STILL IN
THE UNITED STATES?
THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD FEAR ICE
AND THERE'S A GOOD REASON
FOR THAT.
>> Dana: MARIA?
>> Maria: I WILL SAY THERE
IS A PERCEPTION, WE HAVE
SEEN NOT BASED ON WHAT
SENATOR HARRIS SAID BUT
BASED ON REAL PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COME IN TO CONTACT WITH
ICE WHO ARE EITHER TRYING TO
CLAIM ASYLUM WHO HAVE HAD
THEIR.
>> Greg: COMPARE THEM TO THE
KKK?
>> Maria: I'M NOT MAKING
THAT COMPARISON.
WHERE SHE TOOK THE QUESTION
WAS ARE YOU AWARE THERE IS A
PERCEPTION PEOPLE ARE SCARED
WHEN THESE PEOPLE HAVE HAD
THEIR CHILDREN TAKEN FROM
THEM.
SOME OF THEM DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE.
SOME OF THE ADULTS HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BACK WITHOUT THEIR
CHILDREN.
I THINK IT'S A COMPLETELY
FAIR QUESTION TO ASK HIM.
>> Greg: SHE ASKED IT
INCORRECTLY.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
SHE INSERTED THE KKK WHEN
SHE DIDN'T NEED TO DO IT.
>> Maria: THAT'S FINE.
AND I THINK SHE IS WELL
AWARE OF THE HISTORY OF THE
KKK, JESSE.
>> Jesse: SHE SHOULD BE MORE
RESPONSIBLE WITH HER
ANALOGY.
>> Maria: YOU ARE FOCUSING
ON THAT PIECE OF IT.
THE QUESTION WHEN SHE WENT
BACK AND DRILLED BACK DOWN
WAS A COMPLETELY FAIR
QUESTION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
TODAY WHO ARE SCARED OF ICE,
WHO ARE FEARFUL BECAUSE SOME
OF THE STORIES ARE QUITE
FRANKLY HORRIBLE.
>> Dana: SHE IS A LAWYER,
TAMMY, AND IF SHE SAID THAT
IN A COURT OF LAW, DON'T YOU
THINK THERE WOULD BE
OBJECTION?
TAMMY TAMMY PEOPLE MIGHT
HAVE THAT PERCEPTION BECAUSE
OF HER RHETORIC.
>> Maria: NO, BECAUSE OF HER
ACTIONS.
>> Greg: DO THEY ACT LIKE
THE KKK?
>> ON THE BORDER IT'S NOT
ICE SEPARATING FAMILIES.
IT'S THE CUSTOM AND BORDER
PROTECTION, RIGHT?
ICE GOES AFTER PEOPLE WHO
ARE -- GOES AFTER MS-13 AND
THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN MONEY
LAUNDERING, IN DRUG
TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S INTERIOR WORK.
THEY ARE, IN FACT, SAVINGTH
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES FROM
THESE BEASTS THAT TARGET
THEM LIKE MS-13, SO THEY
EVER THE ONES WHO ARE, YOU
KNOW, HELPING THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN IN GENERAL,
CERTAINLY IMMIGRANT
AMERICANS.
SO HER SAYING -- SHE DOESN'T
EVEN REALLY KNOW WHAT ICE IS
DOING.
>> Maria: YES, SHE DOES.
>> LET'S MAKE IT CLEAR IT'S
POSTURING FOR 2020.
>> Dana: SHE KNOWS EXACTLY
WHAT SHE IS DOING.
>> Jesse: SHE IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> IT FELT LIKE THE
KAVANAUGH HEARING AND IT'S
THE SAME ATTITUDE, THE SAME
INSULTING APPROACH, THE SAME
INNUENDO AMERICANS DIDN'T
LIKE THE KAVANAUGH HEARING.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE
IF THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO FOR
TWO YEARS.
IT WILL BACKFIRE.
>> Maria: EVERYTHING CAN'T
BE CRITICIZED AND SAY THIS
IS LIKE KAVANAUGH.
>> BUT IT IS.
>> Greg: THAT'S JUST LIKE
KAVANAUGH.
>> Maria: THERE ARE
CRITICISMS OF ICE THAT CROSS
PARTY BOUNDARIES.
IT'S OKAY.
HE SUSPECT FOR THE POSITION.
HE SHOULD GET ASKED TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
>> BUT REAL ONES.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU THINK ICE
IS GETTING UNFAIRLY SMEARED
BY THE MEDIA?
COME ON.
>> THEY SAVE THE LIVES OF
IMMIGRANTS AND YOUNG WOMEN.
>> Maria: DO HUGE ROUNDUPS
OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> CRIMINAL IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE THERE ARE WARRANTS AND
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY VEHICLES PANED THEIR
POWER BEYOND WHAT THEY USED
TO HAVE.
AND IF WHAT YOU ARE SAYING,
TAMMY IS, TRUE.
IF THAT'S TRUE, HE COULD
HAVE TAKEN THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE THESE FALSE FEARS OUT
THERE, HERE.
>> Greg: PLAYING THE VICTIM,
MARIA.
JUST LIKE KAVANAUGH.
COMPARING THE KKD WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON HERE?
>> Maria: HE COULD HAVE
BATTED DOWN SOME OF THESE
THEORIES IF HE DOESN'T THINK
THEY ARE TRUE.
>> Greg: I WOULD HAVE
FLIPPED OUT.
HE DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
I WOULD HAVE FLIPPED OUT,
MARIA.
SO WOULD YOU.
>> Dana: HE HELD HIS
EXPOSURE.
>> Maria: I DON'T THINK HE
DID.
>> Dana: MARIA, HE HELD HIS
COMPOSURE LIKE DID YOU AT
THE PODIUM.
>> Dana: JIM ACOSTA AND
EARLIER THE JUDGE RULED THAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
MUST REINSTATE HIS PRESS
PASS.
CHRIS WALLACE IS SITTING
DOWN WITH CHRIS WALLACE THIS
WEEKEND FOR "FOX NEWS
SUNDAY."
HE ASKED HIM ABOUT THESE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS.
>> WHAT THEY SAID IS WE HAVE
TO CREATE RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR CONDUCT, ET
CETERA, ET CETERA.
WE ARE DOING THAT WRITE THEM
UP RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
IF HE MISBEHAVES WE WILL
THROW HIM OUT OR STOP THE
NEWS CONFERENCE.
CHRIS: WHAT ARE YOUR RULES
GOING TO BE?
WHAT IS IT YOU ARE SAYING
THIS IS OVER THE LINE?
>> THEY ARE DOING THEM NOW.
WE WILL HAVE RULES OF
DECORUM.
YOU CAN'T KEEP ASKING
QUESTIONS.
WE HAD A LOT OF REPORTERS IN
THAT ROOM.
MANY, MANY REPORTERS IN THAT
ROOM AND THEY WERE UNABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS
GUY GETS UP AND STARTS, YOU
KNOW, DOING WHAT HE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING FOR HIM
AND FOR CNN, AND, YOU KNOW,
JUST SHOUTING OUT QUESTIONS.
AND MAKING STATEMENTS, TOO.
BUT I WILL SAY, THIS LOOK.
NOBODY BELIEVES IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT MORE THAN I DO.
IF I THINK SOMEBODY IS
ACTING OUT OF SORTS, I WILL
LEAVE, I WILL SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY, I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMING AND I
WILL LEAVE.
>> Dana: GREG?
>> Greg: THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS A
VIOLATION OF THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT WHICH IS A RIGHT
TO DUE PROCESS LIKE
KAVANAUGH.
HERE'S THE POINT.
>> Maria: I WILL REGRET
SAYING THAT FOREVER.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA IS NOW UP
IN ARMS OVER THE VIOLATION
OF DUE PROCESS BECAUSE A GUY
LOST HIS HARD PASS EVEN
THOUGH HIS DAILY PASS.
THEY WERE SEEMINGLY VERY
SILENT WHEN A GUY LOST HIS
DUE PROCESS WHEN HE WAS
ACCUSED OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
FROM 35 YEARS AGO.
BY THE WAY I'M FOR DUE
PROCESS FOR EVERYTHING,
OKAY?
I THINK I'M GLAD THEY ARE
FINALLY SAYING HEY, DUE
PROCESS, GOOD THING.
>> Dana: YEAH, WE LO DUE
PROCESS.
THE JUDGE DID NOT RULE,
JESSE, ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUE.
IT WAS THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
ISSUE.
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE, THOUGH,
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING
LIKE WE HAVE MADE OUR POINT
AND ACOSTA IS GOING TO BE
ACOSTA BUT HE MIGHT NOT BE
WELL-THOUGHT OF BY HIS
COLLEAGUES.
>> Jesse: DEFINITELY TIME TO
MOVE ON CONSIDERING THE GUY
WHO MADE THE RULING IS A
THUMP APPROVED JUDGE.
CAN'T SAY THIS IS OBAMA
APPROVED JUDGE.
EVERYBODY IS WILLING ENOUGH
TO TO TAKE A STEP BACK.
I'M JUST GLAD THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS RESTORING DECORUM
AND CIVILITY TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE REPORTERS HAVE BEEN
REALLY RUNNING WILD AND HAVE
BEEN DISRESPECTING THE
TRADITIONS THAT WE SO HOLD
DEAR IN THIS SORT OF PUBLIC.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I'M GLAD THAT THIS IS
BEING RESTORED.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHY
I'M LAUGHING I COULD NOT
AGREE MORE.
>> Maria: IS DONALD TRUMP
GOING TO HAVE TO START
RESPECTING THE DIGNITY OF
THE WHITE HOUSE?
IS HE GOING TO HAVE TO START
ACTING WITH DECORUM?
>> Dana: IS THERE A
PERCEPTION HE IS NOT?
>> Maria: WHEN HE CUTS
PEOPLE OFF AND CALLS THEM
STUPID AND RUDE?
IS HE GOING TO HAVE TO START
PLAYING BY RULES, TOO?
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK HE
HAS ANY RULES.
I THINK HE WAS FINE AND HE
SAID IF ANYBODY ACTS UP WE
ARE GOING TO BOOT HIM.
>> Maria: IT WAS WEIRD TO
WATCH, TAMMY.
>> Jesse: BOOT A LOT OF
REPORTERS BACK IN THE DAY.
LOOK IT UP.
>> Maria: THOMAS JEFFERSON.
JESSE IS ON A HISTORY TEAR
TONIGHT.
>> Jesse: JEFFERSON PULLED A
LOT OF HARD PASSES.
>> DANA, YOU MENTIONED
ACROSS TAPS COLLEAGUES
DOESN'T LIKE WHAT HE DOES,
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONES IN A WAY HAVE TO BE IN
CHARGE TO GET THE LITTLE
CHILD TO SIT DOWN,
OTHERWISE, THE ENTIRE THING
WILL END AND I THINK THAT'S
THE OF THE PRESIDENCY.
PERFECT WAY TO HANDLE IT.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY WILL
PUT HIM IN THE DEEP FREEZE.
EVER PUT ANYBODY IN THE DEEP
FREEZE, MARIA.
>> Maria: HAD TO KICK
SOMEBODY OFF THE PLANE ONE.
>> Jesse: WHO WAS IT.
>> Greg: WAS IT DAVID
GREGORY?